[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 4
juillet voici les titres de cette
édition
la visite de florence parly ce matin à
versailles satory la ministre des armées
s'est rendu sur le site de nexter pour
la réception du griffon et nouveaux
véhicules qui renouvelle la flotte des
blindés de l'armée de terre les
résultats du baccalauréat seront
dévoilés demain une publication perturbé
par la grève des notes opéré par les
correcteurs ils protestent contre la
réforme des lycées et de l'examen
invités de ce journal thibault marshall
professeur de s es au lycée hoche de
versailles
et puis toujours dans le domaine de
l'éducation le départ de la directrice
et enseignants du groupe scolaire
alexandre dumas à montigny le bretonneux
catherine pilot prend sa retraite après
28 ans passés sur place elle était là à
l'ouverture des lieux en 1991 et puis on
parlera cyclisme tout à l'heure dans ce
journal le tour de france bien sûr qui
s'élance ce week-end de belgique
dernière étape au départ des yvelines ce
sera le 28 juillet et les images pour
commencer de cet incendie impressionnant
hier à saint germain en laye le feu
s'est déclaré vers 17 heures dans cette
usine de traitement des eaux à cheval
également sur les commune d'achères et
de maisons laffitte site classé seveso
présents dont présentant donc un risque
elle risque d'accident majeur aucune
victime n'est à déplorer selon la
préfecture des yvelines l'important
nuage de fumée noire qui s'est échappé
n'est pas nocif
aucune mesure de confinement ou
d'évacuation des populations n'a été a
décidé d' incendies qui a été maîtrisé
vers 21h15 les 130 pompiers mobilisés
sur place l'origine du feu qui reste
pour le moment inconnu à saint germain
en laye toujours hier la visite surprise
de christophe castaner dans le quartier
de bel air le ministre de l'intérieur
accompagné et du secrétaire d'état
laurent nunez c'est venu à la rencontre
des habitants après avoir échangé aussi
avec les syndicats de policiers est le
quartier a été le théâtre samedi dernier
de violents affrontements entre bandes
rivales de la ville et de
chanteloup-les-vignes une rixe qui a
fait sept blessés et suscité l'émotion
chez les habitants de saint germain
et direction versailles à présent
florence parly était aujourd'hui sur le
plateau de satory la ministre désormais
a réceptionné à cette occasion le
premier et griffon un véhicule blindé
nouvelle génération est destiné à
l'armée de terre michael et demi d'euros
a suivi ce déplacement
le blindé de demain officiellement
présenté à versailles la ministre des
armées florence par alité ce mercredi 4
juillet sur le plateau de satory pour
réceptionner les six premiers griffon
avec une plaie du programme scorpion qui
renouvelle la gamme de l'armée de terre
le véhicule griffon qui est un véhicule
qui a vocation à remplacer les v abe les
véhicules de l'avant blindés qui ont
rendu de très bons et loyaux services à
nos armées qui ont maintenant près de 40
ans et qui sont prêts si je puis dire de
la retraite les véhicules multi rôles
servira notamment transporter des
troupes l'engin a été conçu en partie
dans l'entreprise nexter sur le plateau
de satory un site qui regroupe plus de
1000 collaborateurs
ici à versailles nous avons la direction
générale de la société le bureau
d'études qui travaille depuis des années
sur la conception de ces véhicules ainsi
que les services achats soutien et
différents services de la direction
générale donc que c'est véritablement la
tête de nexter qui est ici même si les
usines ne se trouvent dans différents
départements français au total près de
1900 véhicule de type griffon seront
livrés d'ici 2030 le blindé sera utilisé
dans un premier temps dans la formation
des militaires
il sera déployé sur le terrain à partir
de 2021 la publication des résultats du
baccalauréat 2010 9 est prévue demain
est ce que tous les élèves auront leur
note même si le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel bloquèrent assure
que oui la publication des résultats du
bac pourrait bien être perturbée depuis
le début de la semaine certains
correcteurs refuse de transmettre leurs
notes en signe de protestation contre la
réforme du bac et vous faites partie de
ces grévistes à thibaut marshall bonsoir
oui bon ça vous êtes professeur de s e s
au lycée hoche de versailles d'ailleurs
une au recteur à auch à correcteur à
auch mais vous êtes professeur de sos
correcteurs à auch voilà vous
l'un d'eux est d'apporter cette
précision alors d'ailleurs une dizaine
d'enseignants font la grève qui font la
grève des notes se sont réunis ce matin
devant le lycée dumont-d'urville à
maurepas d'établissement et centres
d'examen pour le baccalauréat des jurys
devait s'y tenir cet après midi un
rassemblement pour protester contre les
menaces de sanctions de rétention sur
salaire pour les grévistes avancée par à
l'éducation nationale l'occasion aussi
de rappeler l'origine de leur combat à
la réforme du baccalauréat et les motifs
d'opposition les propos sont recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude
sur le fond c'est une réforme qui est
qui va accroître les inégalités entre
les élèves puisque aujourd'hui on va
laisser plus d'autonomie dans les élèves
faire leur choix de spécialités or on
sait très bien que tous les choix de
spécialités ne se valent pas et puis sur
la méthode aussi on a interpellé le
ministre depuis novembre pour justement
essayer de discuter avec lui ce qui a
été refusé
pendant tous ces mois et si la situation
est bloquée aujourd'hui c'est de la
faute du ministre alors on rappelle la
réforme du bac dont les grandes lignes
des filières générales supprimés à la
place un tronc commun pour les élèves
complété par plusieurs enseignements de
spécialité au choix d'un bac 1 qui verra
le jour le 1er back sur cette version ça
sera en 2021
il ya également une part donné au
contrôle continu 40% sur la note finale
les motifs d'opposition à la réforme
vient de les entendre et ce que sont les
mêmes de votre côté bien sûr les deux
principaux axes c'est d'abord le risque
de reproduction sociale c'est à dire
qu'on est sur un système en réalité où
il ya énormément de deux d'implicite
dans le choix d'orientation de pression
des familles de vous l'avez dit une
grosse part du contrôle continu et donc
des établissements qui ne vont pas la
même réputation et donc des bacs
différents selon l'établissement
et puis d'autre part les conditions de
travail et d'enseignement pour les
élèves avec des classes à 35 des groupes
à 35 puisqu'il ya plus de fait classe
qui sont assez généralisé avec des
emplois du temps très difficile pour m
en ce qu'on appelle en barrettes c'est à
dire en alignement toutes les
spécialités possible de choisir donc des
emplois du temps complexe avec des trous
etc etc
donc c'est à la fois
blême d'équité sociale de justice
sociale et de fonctionnement des
établissements
alors je leur précise parce que
l'information erronée un set à fish et
vous êtes bien correcteur au lycée hoche
de versailles le professeur vous êtes
professeur dans un autre lycée des
yvelines professeur de sos justement
utiliser ce levier de la grève des notes
est ce que c'est une sorte de baroud
d'honneur que vous lancez au
gouvernement disons qu'on a vraiment
tout essayé cette année enfin d'ailleurs
même depuis l'année dernière on a fait
des manifestations des pétitions on a
participé aux consultations sur les
programmes moi j'étais élu au conseil
d'administration de mon lycée on a fait
des motions qui ont été transmises au
rectorat etc etc et on a eu un mur face
à nous c'est à dire absence totale de
considération de nos revendications de
nos remarques alors on est plusieurs à
réclamer le retrait total des réformes
mais sans même aller jusque là il ya
quelques petites petits aménagements par
exemple la réforme parle d'or
d'orientation et d'accompagnement
personnalisé mais ces heures là ne sont
pas financées c'est à dire que chaque
établissement de choisir quelle
discipline ne va pas être dédoublé donc
la physique par exemple ils feront pas
de tp pour pouvoir faire de
l'accompagnement personnalisé et dans
telle autre établissement c'est une
autre discipline
on mange sur les enseignements pour
financer sa et donc c'est quelque chose
de simple de nous répondre en disant eh
ben voilà on va donner une enveloppe
pour l'accompagnement personnalisé qu'on
a créés mais ça il n'y répond pas alors
ce soir ce sont au moins cinquante mille
copies qui manquerait 1 d'après
l'éducation nationale même si ce chiffre
pourrait traite pourrait être supérieure
et est ce que dans ce bras de fer
finalement entre vous et et l'éducation
nationale c'est pas les candidats qui
sont les sacrifiés c'est pas eux qui
payent finalement de ce conflit entre
vous et l'éducation
évidemment il n'y a pas de mouvements
sociaux toute façon sans tensions ont
fait pas d'omelette sans casser des
oeufs comme on dit ceci dit les élèves
là nous notre mouvement s'il était tel
que on l'avait imaginé c'est à dire une
grève de trois jours de mardi à jeudi
mardi la remise des notes et jeudi
les jurys sa provoquer un report d'un
jour ou deux
des résultats donc c'est à dire que les
élèves auraient dû attendre un jour ou
deux pour avoir les résultats et tout ça
pour améliorer la situation des
générations à venir c'est à dire qu'en
réalité ce
les élèves d'aujourd'hui ferait avec
tant de générosité comme moi d'ailleurs
je me bats moi personnellement ça va pas
changer énormément de choses sauf que je
vais devenir un vrp de ma discipline et
de mon établissement au lieu de me
contant concentrer sur mes enseignements
mais je perds 200 euros de salaire par
cette grève donc je le fais pas pour mon
plaisir et je pense que les élèves
peuvent y contribuer par ailleurs ils
ont été bien plus perturbé par le fait
par exemple que le mercredi soir des
résultats de parcours super été admis et
que le vendredi on leur annonçait pas
finalement vous êtes sur listes
d'attentes je pense que c'est pire ça de
penser d'être admis et trois jours après
de ne plus l'être que de devoir acheter
attendre un jour ou deux ses résultats
du bac alors tous les élèves auront
leurs notes assuré jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
indiqué sinnott venait à manquer ce
serait une finale en moyenne sur l'année
qui serait appliqué pour la discipline
concernée qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette solution c'est un bricolage qui
s'apparente presqu'à de l'illégalité
parce qu'en fait ils demandent au chef
de centre d'examen de créer une note à
partir du livre et quand ya pas de
livrer parce que c'est un candidat libre
est bien de créer une note tout court à
partir de rien de son envie donc de
créer un faux temporaire qui va être
distribué tamponné par l'administration
comme étant le résultat officiel du bac
à vivre encore heures parce que c'est
celle manquée a indiqué qu offrent les
copies il lève la nôtre la nodyna
l'examen serait supérieur déjà sassi qui
sera hôte
il nous demande de faire quelque chose
d'illégal c'est-à-dire de tamponner un
fond une fausse note et est par ailleurs
c'est de nombreux jurys ont refusé de
les libérer aujourd'hui sur des fausses
notes et ça veut dire que les chefs de
centres d'examen ont délibéré après la
tenue du jury et ont mis des notes et
ont tamponné leur relevé de notes qui
n'est pas validée par le jury donc c'est
totalement illégal selon l'éducation
nationale un mot sur la menace tendu par
le ministre de l'éducation de faire une
rétention sur salaire de 15 jours ça
peut monter jusqu'à 15 jours parce que
c'est à partir du moment où vous a donné
les copier de correction du magal à moi
je me sens
protéger parce que le 1er juillet encore
dernier je remontais à la commission
d'harmonisation de ma discipline ma
moyenne définitive j'étais même au
téléphone avec cette commission
d'harmonisation pour voir parce que
j'avais une moyenne en spécialité qui
était un petit peu différente de celle
de mon jury
donc on a aménagé on a vu qu'elle copie
de pouvait être ré augmenter ou diminuer
donc j'ai les preuves que je travaillais
encore le 1er juillet donc pour moi le
fait de grève commence le mardi 2
juillet et s'il me retire plus et d'agir
au tribunal administratif alors une
dernière réponse en trente secondes on a
quand même le sentiment jean michel
blanquer est totalement fermée à
d'éventuelles négociations du coup pas
de recul du gouvernement qu'est ce que
vous demandez aujourd'hui quand même
alors l'assemblée générale qui se tient
actuellement encore à la bourse du
travail de paris et demande toujours
encore et toujours une revalorisation
des salaires le retrait de la réforme du
lycée le retrait de la loi de l'école de
la confiance le retrait de la réforme du
statut des fonctionnaires
moi je demande juste qu'il ouvre la
porte aux syndicats et qu'ils
réfléchissent à quelques ajustements
pour ma discipline par exemple revoir le
programme qui a été refusée à
l'unanimité il ya eu aucune voix pour au
conseil consultatif de l'enseignement 0
ils sont abstenus où ils ont voté contre
et il est appliqué quand même ce
programme se levant de désajustement
pour un minimum d'heures à effectif
réduit aussi voir je vais être en classe
de seconde avec une heure et demie par
semaine avec des classes à 35 sans
dédoublement parce qu' il manque du
monde
merci thibault marshall pour vos
réponses rappel vous êtes professeur de
ss et vous corriger le bac un correcteur
du baccalauréat au lycée hoche à
versailles
au chapitre éducation encore elle a
ouvert l'école élémentaire alexandre
dumas en 1991 une école devenue depuis
groupe scolaire avec des maternelles
mais aussi toujours dirigée par
catherine pilot ce départ en vacances et
un départ à la retraite pour la
directrice et enseignante elle reportage
de marie lehn iapichino et il eut beau
stand berger
madame pilot enseignante et directrice
de ce groupe scolaire
alexandre dumas vient flairer la bonne
ambiance de ces olympiades qui sentent
bon la fin de l'année scolaire
[Musique]
mais c'est tous se retrouvent à la
rentrée madame pilot elle ne sera plus
dans cette classe qu'elle occupe depuis
28 ans c'est le grand départ celui pour
la retraite
les armoires sont bien rangés prête à à
la passation parce qu'il faut un petit
peu de temps et puis je vous avoue que
je n'ai pas envie de me retrouver au
mois de juillet tout seul dans l'école a
arrangé en 28 ans est celle de classe a
évolué
les murs ont changé de couleur et le
mobilier s'est modernisé les souvenirs
eux restent inscrits c'est qu'un seul
regret j'aurais dû noter toutes les
bêtises toutes les petites et blagues
les petites choses qui j'aurais dû les
noter comme ça je retrouverai j'aurais
dû ouvrir un cahier puis notez tout ça
est ce qu'il ya un autre métier dans
lequel fa qui apporte autant de joie ait
autant de monde de bonheur quoi de si je
sais pas je suis pas sûr tu pas sur ce
que les enfants ils ont une spontanéité
et une tendresse ou confiance qu'on perd
pourtant grandissant ça j'ai adoré j'ai
adoré faire smic
madame pilot enseigne au cm2 une tranche
d'âge qu'elle a toujours conservé
elle est aussi la directrice tout est
prêt pour ma remplaçante ouvre en fait
même étiqueté tout pour que ce soit plus
simple pour elle j'appréhende m qui peut
parce que je me demande ce qui commence
à être la retraite mais je suis prête à
partir un nouveau départ et des bons
souvenirs
alors pour une directrice qui aura
autant marqué l'histoire de son école
impossible de passer à côté du pot de
départ un groupe de parents d'élèves ces
mêmes constitués en comité
d'organisation pour que la fête soit
réussie
près de 300 personnes se sont réunies et
on a eu en a qui sont venus du périgord
united roumanie il a pris l'avion pour
revenir de roumanie
je vous dis c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de bonheur
ouais c'est plein d'émotions plein de
souvenirs qui reviennent et danser une
directrice en or il n'y a pas d'autre
moi c'est vraiment exceptionnel des
discours de nombreux cadeaux une chanson
pour dire au revoir et chapeau à cette
pétillante madame pilot dans l'actualité
la commune nouvelle avait voté en
conseil municipal allait au nom de
jonathan sont de leur a été inaugurée
c'est un axe piéton à proximité de la
bibliothèque on est dans la ville un du
chéné rocancourt hommage bien sûr à cet
enseignant de 30 ans victime du
terrorisme il a été tué avec ses jeunes
enfants harry et gabriel est devant
l'école juive ozar hatorah le 19 mars
2012 la famille chandler a habité le
chesnay dans les années 80 et jonathan
ya fréquenté l école maryse bastié
c'était en 86 et 1987 transports les
dispositifs le dispositif d arrêt à la
demande est étendue dans les yvelines ce
service jusque là expérimenté dans le 93
permet aux usagers et des bus de
demander au chauffeur de descendre entre
deux arrêts et ce après 22h l'objectif
c'est d'améliorer le sentiment de
sécurité le soir dans les transports
notamment pour les femmes et dans le
département 13 lignes sont concernées
par la nouveauté la liste qui apparaît
elles sont toutes dans le nord- yvelines
aux mureaux par exemple ou encore
poitiers sartrouville et des lignes du
réseau bus en scène si à 2-0 encore
airbus
elle est spécialisée dans la mobilité
pour collaborateurs des entreprises de
l'agglomération l'association delta sky
a organisé un challenge plusieurs
startups ont proposé leur solution de
mobilité et injures
a décerné ses prix une cérémonie s'est
tenue hier à paris si nicolas landry 5
start-up cinq propositions de mobilité
innovante c'est le challenge organisé
par l'association delta sky le principe
trouver des solutions pour la mobilité
des salariés de saint quentin en
yvelines
l'idée du chalenge c'était de de
susciter la créativité des start-up leur
agilité pour trouver des solutions
innovantes qui apportent des choses très
concrètes qui peuvent être mises en
oeuvre rapidement simplement
efficacement et dans un délai court qui
a des mobilités complémentaires et c'est
ça qui est un des c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est d'avoir un large panel
qui permettent justement de s'adapter à
tous les profils et à tous les âges
un service de location de trottinettes
électriques en station une solution
développée par we trust
c'est le premier prix de ce challenge
avec un projet en cours d'élaboration
cinq à sept kilomètres autour de la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines
la zone était tendue elle va partir du
pôle mobilité du transport sur un à
trois kilomètres déjà pour démarrer sur
montigny et ensuite on va élargir sur la
clé sous bois et en travail soit un
projet aussi sur son voisin boutonneux
autre start-up lauréate de ce concours
ce moving avec son concept de véhicule
de transport collectif et écologique en
forme de lieu de travail
c'est le mobile office l'idée c'est de
reproduire tout le le confort et les
services qu'on a dans un bureau fixe et
de le rendre mobiles et de faire en
sorte de transformer le temps de trajet
en temps de travail opérationnel avec le
confort et l'efficacité d'un bureau fixe
enfin supra wise a aussi obtenu un prix
cette start up est en train de
développer ce système de mobilité
innovants sur le territoire respectez
les enjeux environnementaux pour la
construction proposer un habitat qui est
répond aux besoins l'objectif de la
charte de la promotion immobilière
résidentielle
elle a été signé aujourd'hui à la salle
du conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines entre
l'agglomération les promoteurs
immobiliers et les villes plusieurs
années de travail pour aboutir à cette
charte qui garantit trois axes majeurs
la qualité du logement à celles du cadre
de vie et la fluidité des relations
entre les différents acteurs de
l'immobilier les promoteurs respectant
leur engagement se verront remettre le
label quali sky par l'agglomération les
interviews collectées par patrick
jacques de dixmude ont souhaité réguler
un petit peu cette construction cette
façon de construire en instaurant un
vrai dialogue entre les communes et les
promoteurs alors non pas qu'il y en
avait pas du tout mais on s'est dit ce
serait bien de travailler ensemble faire
des arts on a fait des ateliers où on a
échangé les promoteurs ont pu nous
donner leurs propres contraintes et
leurs propres attentes
et puis de l'autre côté toutes les
communes qui ont participé ont aussi
donné leurs attentes et leurs
contraintes
la charte al'avantage de regrouper
l'ensemble des des points qui sont des
points sur lesquels notre société très
très vigilante donc une qualité de
l'habitat une qualité de prestation
un confort de vie
là le développement durable qui soit le
plus développé possible et tout ça en
partenariat avec avec les collectivités
ce que j'ai trouvé très très positif
dans cette charte qui m'a été présenté
et son côté non pas obligataires mais
incitateur et je pense que quand on
incite et qu'on amène les gens ce genr
forcément une création de valeur et
surtout une dynamique d'essayer d'aller
plus loin ou autrement
mais le sport il va animer tout le mois
de juillet le tour de france 2010 9
débute ce samedi 106e grande boucle au
départ de la belgique une première étape
au départ de bruxelles le passage dans
les yvelines lui est prévue le 28
juillet dernière étape entre rambouillet
et les champs-elysées pour en parler
jean françois guy borrel bonsoir bonsoir
gagne henry ancien coureur cycliste vous
a été présélectionné notamment en équipe
de france pour les jo 1976 21 tours de
france à votre actif sur france
télévisions tous fini en voiture et vous
êtes également l'ambassadeur du
vélodrome nationale l'un des
ambassadeurs du vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
une première question sur ce tour de
france trois mille quatre cent soixante
kilomètres vingt-et-une étapes pour
cette édition 2010 note puisqu'ils
s'annonce bien pour vous ce tour oui
c'est toujours la plus grande plus
grande course au monde et je pense que
tous les fervents du cyclisme attendent
fébrilement cet événement et puis cette
année je pense que c'est peut-être la
première année où les français ont
vraiment de grandes chances
thibaut pinot et gamay alaphilippe
éventuellement pour le maillot moi je
dirais même maillot vert pourquoi pas et
grimpeurs en sachant que le dernier
maillot jaune sur le tour de france
c'était tony gallopin en 2014 derniers
ont elles porté brièvement brillamment
sur les étagères cette année d'ailleurs
c'est grosse grosse fête à bruxelles
départ de ce tour de france qui a lieu
donc samedi départ avec bien sûr une
grande commémoration pour eddy merckx
qui est le quai de là bas donc vous
pensez que le maillot jaune pour être de
nouveau porté par un français cette
année tout simplement c'est que
il ya toujours toujours ces grosses
équipes comme stan a comme aline eos
anciennement skywalker gerraint thomas
bernhard ce petit colombien qui a
remporté le dernier parisien maintenant
au tour de suisse au tour de suisse est
qui et qui a eu un accident en début de
saison qu'il avait à faire prendre
beaucoup de beaucoup d'énergie et il
arrive dans ce tour de france très frais
pas de christopher froome pas de mark
cavendish vous parliez de guérande
thomass qui a lourdement chuté il ya
quelques jours
ça va je pense qu'il veut oui il sera
l'un des favoris le gros favori oui et
puis il y en a un grand rien gros qui
manque si c'est tom dumoulin comme
déroulant les cakes un gros problème au
genou
dans cette année il ya possibilité
d'ailleurs j'ai peut-être pas être parce
qu'on peut jamais dire jamais mais je
pense que si cette année les français
gagnent pas ils vont encore beaucoup de
temps avant de le gagner quoi aussi
peut-être du coup donc je gagne comme à
son rappel ces derniers vainqueurs de
l'édition 2018 jakob fulsang le danois
bien sûr aussi astana avec une grosse
équipe
il ya aussi il faut pas laisser de
kintana avec avec valverde qui est le
champion du monde et qui est valverde a
me semble d'une forme je suis passé
parce que c'est plus on vieillit mais on
est mais c'est impressionnant et il
marche comme un voleur alors si on
résume le parcours un début en belgique
premier massif dès la 5e étape dans les
vosges une 14e étape qui s'achèvera elle
au sommet du tourmalet et après
troisième semaine bien sûr avec eux le
franchissement de plusieurs cols de
haute montagne dans les alpes une longue
montée jusqu'à à val thorens pour
l'avant dernière étape le parcours il
est au rendez vous est très très très
dur
les pièges d'autres contrats montrent
peu de contrôle demande donc avec le
cadre le contre la montre par équipes
qui a lieu deuxième jour c'est à dire
que je pense que déjà les équipes vont
poser leurs pions et va pas falloir
prendre perdre beaucoup trop de temps
c'est toujours un peu difficile et
conservant deux par équipe parce que ça
demande beaucoup de cohésion et puis
l'effervescence du tour c'est le début
beaucoup de monde sur les routes c'est
c'est pas facile un tour de france pour
pour de jeunes coureurs nous précise que
le point culminant 1 de ce tour c'est
2007 170 m et c'est le col de l'iseran
et bien sûr dans les alpes alors si on
parle de la dernière étape cette fois ci
dans les yvelines on l'a dit une étape à
rambouillet départ de rambouillet le 28
juillet déjà que ce soit dans les
yvelines
c'est une bonne chose cette année paris
nice par des yvelines ça fait 10 ans
notamment il ya une convention
d'ailleurs de signer et je crois que de
plus en plus en plus on va aller vers
les jeux olympiques puis on aura des
manifestations
superbe parce que c'est concerne le vélo
c'est un territoire propice pour oui
parce qu'elle avait eu l'heureuse bien
que je trouve qu'elle est plus en plus
encombré de véhicules à quatre roues
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
c'est quand même une région oms et un
poumon vert c'est bien de encore
respirer et surtout on peut on peut
faire du vélo y être très très belle
cote
il ya on est vite dans la nature mais il
faut le préserver tout ça et là dernier
je voulais venir sur revenir sur le
dernier top un peu embêtant que
maintenant la dernière étape soit
toujours un petit peu une procession
c'est à dire que le maillot jaune et on
collait pas pour ainsi dire acquis
et à qui on connaît fera sur l'étape de
val pense rester là bas c'est toujours
un peu embêtant parce que il ya encore
de quoi faire entre entre rambouillet et
champs elysées il ya des 47 par exemple
robbie qui a gagné à lors de la dernière
étape il a attaqué et c'était je pense
qu'il faut revenir faut pas que le tour
se termine avant dernière étape fois
c'est une étape de 128 km le profil
brasser les plats rachat va être pour
les routiers-sprinters pour ça que
beaucoup préconise de revenir un petit
peu au tour de france avec avec un
contre-la-montre en dernière étape parce
qu'un contre la montre
regardez lemond fignon ça a été quand
même c'était pas fait quoi et ça a été
au niveau du suspense était vraiment
bien il y aura un passage en parler de
la vallée de chevreuse cette belle
vallée de chevreuse y aura un passage
dans la vallée de chevreuse rappel cette
étape de 128 km au départ de rambouillet
direction les champs elysées ce sera le
28 juillet prochain
merci à vous et grégory jean françois
guy morel ancien coureur cycliste et
ambassades japon nationale venait au
vélodrome 1 nombreuses initiations qui
sont behrendt hamas d'ailleurs vous
posez c'est est un ancien pistard voilà
on que bien sûr des initiations de vélo
de piste 1 / sur le vélodrome nationales
merci beaucoup merci
c'est la fin du set 8 journal un replay
bien sûr sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile que faire pour
se divertir ce week-end dans les
yvelines
marylène iapichino vous donne quelques
idées de sorties c'est dans un instant
le 7-8 loisirs sur tv 78 belle soirée à
tous
[Musique]